la menace d'une deuxième vague de covile
19 se précise
en chine un foyer de contamination a été
repéré dans un marché de pékin une
situation qui a poussé le gouvernement à
ordonner le confinement de plusieurs
quartiers résidentiels
malgré un regain de k2 coronavirus les
habitants de la capitale reste serein il
ya eu de la panique lors de la première
vague mais pour la deuxième vague
il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter nous
avons les données le gouvernement
contrôle les choses strictement la
population est vigilante
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème il
n'y a pas de raison de paniquer je pense
qu'ici ça va après tout c'est très loin
tous ces gens vont être testés alors ça
va en plus le flux de personnes est
limitée ici donc je ne suis pas très
inquiète
inquiétude en revanche en iran pays du
moyen orient le plus touché par le
coronavirus ou le ministère de la santé
enregistre un rebond de décès dus à la
maladie
une situation que regrette hassan rohani
le président iranien reproche à ses
citoyens un relâchement dans le respect
des mesures sanitaires
on nous a lu pendant cette réunion un
rapport inquiétant selon lequel le
respect des consignes sanitaires par
notre cher peuple a été formidable
jusqu'à plus de 80% du 20 avril au 20
mai mais aujourd'hui on voit que cela a
beaucoup diminué depuis le 4 juin avec
seulement 18 % à 20 % de gens qui les
respectent vision c'est également en
europe face au risque d'une deuxième
vague de kovy 19 alors que l'italie a
rouvert ses frontières depuis le 3 juin
deux foyers de contamination ont été
repérés à rome le premier dans un
immeuble d'habitation le deuxième dans
une structure hospitalière
une situation qui inquiète alors que
plusieurs pays rétablissent la libre
circulation avec le reste de l'union
européenne